having your ordinary life
unceremoniously change Forever Without a
moment's notice is something that people
can often find themselves hoping for
anything to break life's monotony and
change circumstances to make them more
interesting although when that change
comes in the form of being trapped in an
endless Ikea Outlet it's not exactly the
different kind of circumstances that
people usually hope for that was the
situation that had befallen Winston not
too long ago what started as a
simplistic straightforward shopping trip
with a goal of purchasing some
affordable stylish Swedish Furniture had
resulted in him having to adopt a
completely different lifestyle you see
Winston was one of the untold number of
people to have an encounter with
scp-3008 better known colloquially as
the infinite Ikea appearing as an
ordinary store those entering the doors
of scp-3008 find themselves in an
unending Labyrinth of Isles upon Isles
filled with flat pack homeware it can be
quite the System Shock of course
especially when people that find
themselves inside the infinite Ikea
learn there's no way to escape even by
retracing their steps back the way they
came doing so they'll only be met with a
disheartening realization that the
entrance isn't where it was upon their
arrival now at first learning that
you've lost your entire life and are
doomed to spend the rest of your days
inside a limitless Ikea is admittedly a
lot to take in your friends family job
all your worldly possessions are now
unreachable and everyone back home might
likely spend many years wondering what
happened to you but it's not all bad
news as previously mentioned Winston
wasn't the only one to find himself in
this predicament over the years
countless people have found their way
inside the infinite Ikea given how
expansive the interior of the
never-ending store was there has never
been a way to know for certain exactly
how many people have come to reside
within
scp-3008 but it's enough to populate the
number of small settlements that these
survivors have been able to establish
Inside by innovatively repurposing the
materials around them these individuals
have found themselves to be the new
denizens of scp-3008 Imagine whole towns
constructed from chairs and tables that
have been used as building materials to
provide a place of sanctuary to those
that need it when they first arrive in
the infinite Ikea sure it takes a pretty
big adjustment to this new lifestyle but
luckily
scp-3008 provides for its inhabitants by
automatically replenishing the food
within its canteen naturally it only
offers items that are on the Ikea menu
but that's at least a consistent source
of food and nutrition for those dwelling
in its aisles with food already taken
care of people inside
scp-3008 didn't even need to work that
was the strangest part that Winston
found himself having to adapt to when he
first got to the settlement of cookware
named after the nearby sign that hung
from the ceiling nearby denoting one of
the many departments of the store it was
odd to him how friendly everyone was how
much the people trapped inside 3008 cut
off from the outside world forever
seemed happy there were many who'd been
there for the longest that even claimed
it was a better sense of life than out
there in the real world inside the Ikea
there was a strong sense of community
settlements helped each other out with
construction and because everything was
provided for no one had any need for
selfishness or greed after all there was
plenty of food to go around and money
had no relevance ironic given they were
all living inside a huge Furniture Store
witnessing all of that helped Winston
adapt to his new life inside as CPU 3008
and made him feel a lot better about
being in this predicament the only real
thing anyone inside the infinite Ikea
had to worry about was the threat of the
staff these were the Tall Face humanoids
with elongated arms then legs that
roamed the aisles of the furniture store
while wearing distinctive Ikea uniforms
most of the time they remain docile
paying the human survivors little
attention that is until the fluorescent
lights above dimmed signaling the
beginning of night time the staff
usually became aggressive repeating the
ominous phrase the store is now closed
please exit the building and attacking
anyone they came into contact with
thanks to their Ingenuity the survivors
in the Ikea had constructed barriers
around their settlements to keep the
staff out and that did the trick
repelling The Faceless employees that
come at night but little did anyone
inside
scp-3008 realize that simple barricades
wouldn't stop an entirely new threat
from entering the store to disrupt their
peaceful way of life for outside the
infinite Ikea Something Wicked was
stirring meanwhile at a facility
belonging to the SCP Foundation a
researcher by the name of Corbin Donnell
had recently been assigned to
scp-035 also known as the possessive
mask this white porcelain mask could
shift between a comedy grin or a tragic
frown it also had the nasty trait of
being an evil psychic artifact that
could manipulate anyone around it into
placing the mask over their face at that
point
scp-035 would take full control of its
wearer making them into a host for the
mask itself so would you like to take a
guess as to what happened to researcher
Donnell the voice in his head that
persuasive whisper it wouldn't leave him
alone all day long it was there but
whenever Corbin was near
scp-035 it got louder and as the days he
was studying the possessive mask went on
the whisper became a shout the screams
to put on the mask were taunting him
keeping him awake at night tormenting
him all through the waking day until
eventually he'd had enough given that
scp-035 produced a corrosive black
substance that usually melted anything
around it the mask had to periodically
be taken out of its containment case so
that the container housing it could be
replaced and it was during one of these
transfers that researcher done now
calmly swept in pushing away the guards
taking it out of its melted case before
they could place it in a new one the
aggression from the researcher caught
the security Personnel by surprise as
did what he did next not caring what the
possessive mask would do to him Corbin
lifted the white porcelain to his face
he wasn't even aware that the
Containment Breach alarms were sounding
all that noise sank into the background
as the psychic voice in his head got
louder than it ever had before there
wasn't even so much as a split-second
awareness from researcher Danelle of the
Searing pain as the dark sludge oozing
from The Mask made contact with his skin
melting his face as he wore
scp-035 by that point it was already too
late the possessive mask had full
control Corbin's body wasn't his own
anymore although it still moved walking
quickly out of the room and through the
halls of the foundation facility the
researcher beneath was already dead
there was only
scp-035 piloting its newest host to
freedom of course while a Containment
Breach was still an urgent matter the
foundation knew that scp-035's biggest
weakness was itself the black secretion
that poured out of the possessive mask
would melt anything it came into contact
with and would ultimately cause the body
of its hose to melt into nothing once
that happened it would be far easier to
recontain as cp035 someone would merely
have to pick it up and place it back in
the containment case however scp-035
knew this too The Mask itself was
cunning it hadn't just picked researcher
denial at random to be its new vehicle
it wanted him specifically because says
of his previous posting before he had
worked with scp-035 Corbin had been
stationed to observe any potential
changes at the entrance of
scp-3008 as it stayed firmly on the
researcher's face using him to carry
itself out of the foundation's site it
had been trapped in
scp-035 was scouring the remnants of
Corbin's mind it used its innate psychic
abilities to plunder the depths of his
brain looking for information the
location of scp-3008 was right there
stored away safely and researcher
donel's memories as was the way to get
there and on top of that the reason
scp-035 had taken such an interest in
making it to the infinite Ikea during
the foundation's many years of study and
exploration of scp-3008 they came to
learn that not all of the survivors
inside the infinite Ikea had originated
from the same universe the current
theory was that the entrances to this
endless furniture store existed
simultaneously in multiple realities
meaning that the people now living
alongside each other inside
scp-3008 were actually from varying
different worlds across the Multiverse
now if you were incredibly cunning
incredibly clever and Incredibly sick of
being held captive by the foundation
then perhaps you could figure out a way
to navigate your way through the
infinite Ikea you could enter through
the front door in one universe and then
exit into another and of course that was
what the possessive mask was planning to
do as it approached the main entrance of
scp-3008 the black sludge leaking out of
the Mask had almost destroyed what was
left of researcher Corbin Donnell it
wiped more of the corrosive secretion
onto the guards stationed at the
infinite Ikea melting through them as
scp-035 made its way inside first things
first The Mask knew it had to find
itself a new body to Pilot before
Corbin's expired and it didn't take long
for The Possession of masks to happen
across an unwitting candidate between
the aisles of flat packed tables at
around the same time this was happening
Winston having long since gotten used to
the Rhythm of Life inside
scp-3008 was on his way to the food
court he knew the route by heart now and
as he strolled closer he was pondering
over what he'd help himself to today
from a menu but it was while making his
way there that he noticed something or
rather he noticed not something that he
usually did there were no staff anywhere
around although they did not pay the
survivors any mind during the day when
the lights of the Ikea were on Winston
knew that the staff members were always
present there were usually a couple
Milling about the aisles he had to pass
in order to get from the settlement of
cookware to the Food Hall but today
there were none and while this wouldn't
usually be any cause for alarm it kept
playing on Winston's mind as he sat down
to eat his plate of Swedish meatballs
he'd been inside scp-3008 for such a
long time that he'd become accustomed to
the routine of living there and the
absence of the staff immediately stuck
out as something that was out of its
usual place finishing his food Winston
asked around talking with his fellow
residents of the infinite Ikea asking if
any of them had encountered any of the
tall faceless staff members on their way
to get their meals each and every one of
them that he asked from burying
different settlements all answered the
same that they hadn't spotted any staff
all day as much as they were A Minor
Threat to the human beings living inside
the infinite Ikea the absence of the
store's only other residents kept
playing on Winston's mind whatever was
going on the staff seemingly Vanishing
couldn't mean anything good and so he
decided to venture out into the aisles
to figure out what exactly was going on
what he found was unlike anything anyone
had ever seen in
scp-3008 before it took Winston several
long and uneventful hours to catch even
a momentary glimpse of a staff member he
almost felt like someone trekking
through a forest looking to get a
sighting of Bigfoot or some other
elusive urban legend but as the third
hour became the fourth he spotted a hint
of movement between the aisles following
at a safe distance listening out for the
slightest sounds Winston couldn't help
but think he detected the noise of
something heavy being dragged along the
stone floor peeking out from between the
aisles he saw them a huge group of Staff
members were all huddled in a display
dining room only there was something
different about all of them they still
retained their recognizable tall and
humanoid shapes with long
disproportionate limbs but there was
something smeared over the staff a dark
oily black substance that seemed to melt
through the floor as it dripped off them
from his Hiding Place Winston soon saw
where that substance had originated from
the thing being dragged across the floor
was another staff member looking more
normal than the rest one of the other
covered in the corrosive sludge was
gripping it by the color of its Ikea
polo shirt and bringing it through the
group meanwhile the ordinary creature
was thrashing and flailing its lengthy
arms around trying to get free it was
dragged up to a staff member in the
middle of the group which turned and
shocked Winston at the strange side of
it this staff member evidently the
leader had a face or rather it was
wearing a mask
scp-035 was now firmly affixed to the
Slender faceless being its expression
locked in a wide grin that seemed to
convey a twisted sense of Glee its black
secretion didn't seem to be affecting
its new host in the same way it usually
did the body of the staff member it was
now piloting didn't seem to dissolve as
the uncorrupted staff creature was
presented to the masked leader
scp-035 compelled its Newfound followers
to restrain their prisoner the workers
within scp-3008 didn't have much in the
way of their own free will or even
personalities to speak of they did
however seem to share some sort of
connection to each other a hive mine of
sorts so presented with a powerful
psychic Force like the possessive Mask
The Entity had been able to not only
take over one of the staff members as
its new host but spread its influence to
the others and while Winston watched
horrified it unknowingly demonstrated
this the captive staff member was
grabbed and held by the others its long
arms and legs pulled apart the huddled
group lifted it up off the floor so that
it couldn't free itself and run off into
the endless aisles of furniture wearing
scp-035 the leader extended an arm black
ooze dripping from it the droplets
burning Holes in the Floor as it reached
towards the faceless head of the
restrained staff member it placed a
large hand over the faceless head of the
captive more of the corrosive secretion
passed on to the newest addition to
scp-035's Growing Army as the black
substance spread over the staff member
so did the influence of the possessive
mask Force its way into another vessel
I'm telling you I know what I saw
Winston protested after recounting the
offense to the other settlers back at
cookware there's something else out
there something new and dangerous and
it's infecting the staff oh that's
ridiculous replied Bryce one of the
survivors who had been there much longer
I've been here for years and I've never
even heard of such a thing they yelled I
saw it with my own eyes Winston argued
it has a small army of them already
under its control even if what you're
saying is true someone else chimed in
why does it matter we've already got
barriers to keep the staff out and they
only attack at night anyways surely even
if this mask thing really is in control
of them now who cares as if On Cue one
of the Lookouts at the cookware
settlement started frantically trying to
get everyone's attention they pointed to
the ominous glow coming from just beyond
the nearby Isles filled with wardrobe
frames an orange flicker was visible
even Under The Lights of the store which
were still on although blocked a little
by thick plumes of black smoke rising up
towards the ceiling that's lighting the
lookout said in shock disbelief stating
the name of another nearby community of
survivors that was named after an Ikea
store Department something must have
happened over there Bryce declared uh
maybe it's an electrical fire that's
gotten out of control it's them Winston
said solemnly it can't be them the older
Survivor snapped the lights are still on
it's still daytime in the store and the
staff never attacked during the day I
don't think the rules are the same
anymore frustrated Winston continued to
argue there's no telling what that mass
did to them uh perhaps Bryce was trying
desperately to come up with a suggestion
but was clearly grasping at straws one
of this mask can be reasoned with if
it's more intelligent than the staff we
can we can negotiate there must be
something it wants what do you think it
wants it wants this place this Ikea and
now it has control of enough staff to
form a small army you think it's just
gonna stop there it's coming for all of
us and it won't stop until it's got the
whole store under its control and if it
has to wipe us out to do that well it
looks like it's not hesitating so what
do we do a voice called meekly Winston
turned to see the town's folk of
cookware had gathered all looking up at
him with terrified Expressions on their
faces he gaze back at each one of them
then looked back over at the smoke now
towering over where lighting had been
and was now in Flames who knew how many
of the settlers there were still alive
and how long it would be before
scp-035 and its new Army did the same to
cookware something had to be done we
need to get the word out Winston
announced to the other survivors I need
our fastest run over to the other towns
in the store you each take one you pass
on the message and then you come back
you know your way around well enough so
avoid anywhere you'd normally see staff
even if they haven't been corrupted we
can't chance it why don't we tell the
other settlements somebody in the crowd
called you tell them what's going on you
say that something has come here to
threaten this Ikea and our way of life
this play isn't where any of us first
came from but it's all our home now it's
provided for us but now it needs us to
defend it Winston exclaimed and how
exactly are we gonna do that Bryce asked
the lights had gone out but although
night had fallen it wasn't Dark Yet
standing with their fellow survivors
from numerous other settlements the
residents of scp-3008 had fashioned
flaming torches from the legs of Ikea
desks and tables and that wasn't all
they were carrying makeshift weapons
some had Spears crafted using curtain
rails with sharp kitchen implements
fashioned to the end others had wardrobe
doors in their hands to act as
rudimentary Shields they were hardly
Warriors but as an army of corrupted
staff members lurched out of the
darkness towards them each Survivor of
scp-3008 knew what they had to do at the
front of the army towered the staff
member with scp-035 on its faceless head
the possessive mask's wide grin had
shifted now a long frown almost one of
discussed at the amass settlers who
opposed it as it raised an elongated arm
to command its horde Winston raised a
curtain rail spear into the air for Ikea
as the residents of
scp-3008 charged want to own an SCP of
your own go to scpswag.com for premium
anomalous merchandise now go check out
what if scp-343 war scp-035 and SCP-173
surprises scp-3008 Shoppers for more
anomalous surprises